ça y est les gars j'ai trouvé du boulot
je vais gagner des Millions approchez
tous on va boire laapéro pour
l'inauguration fini pour moi de bailler
toute la nuit dans ce mauvais vist sur
les ongles et su vernis j'ai trouvé
boulot c'est ma Janine qui a rencontré
quelqu'un qui connaîtrait quelqu'un qui
chercherait quelqu'un c'est très facile
c'est dans un cabaret B vraiment cabaret
mais quand même cabaret ça y est les
gars j'ai trouvé du boulot me la pensé
pour joie et va falloir que je paye des
impôts pour ceux qui travaillent pas de
notre côté la retraite des vieux des
avantages sociaux ma chre Jine elle m'a
ouvert les yeux en trouvant du
boulot s fait ce qu'on dit au moment
qu'on dit à qui c'est qu'on dit c'est
les voyages comme chanteus en Turquie
comme danseuse en Turquie là-bas à r en
Turquie ça y est les gars j'ai trouvé du
boulot vous
ver ma fiancée installé en tout gros au
affiches du
ciné comprendrez qu'il faut se lever
pour
décrocher salut les gars j'ai trouvé du
[Musique]
boulot